the best horror movie villains are more
than just
monsters they're reminders of your own
mortality who play on your worst fears
and make you question the things you
hold most dear
that's what makes a terrifying villain
and these are the most terrifying of all
michael myers first struck the sleepy
town of haddenfield in 1978's halloween
and four decades later he's still at it
myers has faced his fair share of
reboots and retcons over the years
but despite it all the man himself
remains pretty much the same
he's still got the gray jumpsuit the
william shatner mask
and the motivation to keep on moving no
matter what
in the original halloween myers was
credited simply as
the shape and that's because michael
isn't a person
he's the boogeyman with a butcher's
knife and the devil's eyes
he prowls through suburban neighborhoods
like an apex predator
always searching for his next victim and
what makes him truly terrifying is that
in the original movie at least there's
no method to his madness
michael kills people because that's what
michael does
and there's no logic to it he's random
violence personified
worse still no matter how hard you try
you can't stop this guy
no matter what you do he's gonna get up
and keep coming
all you can do is run and hope that the
man in the mask
doesn't catch you cinema is practically
crawling with evil aliens but when it
comes to inspiring
pure primal horror you can't get any
freakier than the xenomorph
designed by the legendary artist h.r
geiger the xenomorph first appeared in
1979's alien
and has since become known as one of
cinema's most iconic sci-fi villains
after starting off as a leathery egg the
xenomorph's first form is that of the
parasitic face hugger
which implants a chest burster into the
body of its victim
the chest burster then does well pretty
much exactly what you expect it to and
quickly evolves into the perfect killing
machine that is the fully grown
xenomorph from its unsettlingly phallic
head to its dripping
snarling maw the creature looks like a
reproductive organ come to life
one that wants nothing more than to turn
you into an
incubator for more baby xenomorphs
by far the worst thing about the
xenomorph is it isn't just a killer
it's a violator a genuine monster that
does all manner of unspeakable things to
the
bodies of its victims this is a creature
designed to get under your skin
because that's the last place you want
it to be i can't lie to you about your
chances
but
know my sympathies fighting off a
terrifying monster is never fun
but it's always a little easier with a
buddy by your side
but what if you can't trust your friends
because one of them could become that
monster at any moment
welcome to the world of the thing
directed by john carpenter
this 1982 horror classic finds a group
of snowbound scientists battling a slimy
shapeshifter that can impersonate
anything or anyone
that's what makes this alien so
frightening when the thing is on the
loose
you can't even trust your own senses
sure that guy standing next to you might
look and sound like the man you've known
for years
but he still might bite your head off
the second you turn your back
that's when the paranoia sets in
suddenly friends start turning on
friends
all while the actual monster is killing
everybody off
one by one this adds a whole new level
of fear to an already terrifying
situation
and makes the thing one of the most
unique and horrifying villains in the
history of cinema
the scariest thing in the world is the
idea of losing control
and when you think about it that's
exactly what you do whenever you go to
sleep
after crawling into bed you slip into
unconsciousness where
for most people the mind goes absolutely
wild
but hey if you do find yourself trapped
in a horrific nightmare you can at least
be glad you'll wake up unharmed
unless you're sharing that dream with
freddy krueger of course
the sweater sporting villain from the
nightmare on elm street franchise
freddie revels in taunting his victims
before finishing them off
usually in brutally inventive ways of
course
there are plenty of slashers out there
with a little dramatic flair
but what sets freddy apart from the pack
is the way he invades your mind
and completely takes over freddy is
basically the god of nightmares
the laws of physics don't apply in the
dream world so freddie can create
any scenario he wants theoretically your
bedroom should be the safest place in
your home
and when you close your eyes at night
you'll fully expect to wake up the next
morning
but when freddy krueger is lurking in
the shadows of your subconscious
there's no guarantee you'll live to see
the sunrise worst of all there's just no
getting away from him either
after all you can't fight sleep forever
the silence of the lambs features one of
the greatest serial killers in cinematic
history
but while hannibal lecter is a villain
for the ages he's not
really the movie's principal villain
he's not even the scariest
after all there's something kind of
charming about him you might despise
what he's done
but you also can't help but admire him
because he's witty
refined and thanks to anthony hopkins
he's absolutely electric to watch too
a census taker once tried to test me
i ate his liver with some fava beans
and a nice chianti jane gum however
is none of those things played by ted
levine gum
is a genuine monster with a deeply
disturbing kind of
animal cunning when it comes to hunting
women maybe he's so unsettling because
he's so realistic
in fact gum is most likely an amalgam of
three
real-life murderers ted bundy ed gein
and gary heidnik so whenever buffalo
bill shimmies onto the screen
your skin can't help but crawl
occasionally a flash of empathy creeps
back into his mind but for the most part
he sees his victims as nothing more than
sacks of meat
made to serve his despicable needs and
while it's freaky to imagine yourself at
the mercy of freddy krueger or the
xenomorph
gum's dungeon is far far worse because
one day
you might actually find yourself down
there who killed laura palmer
for better or worse twin peaks fans got
their answer in season two of the
seminal tv show
when it was revealed the homecoming
queen was killed by her own father
leland palmer well sort of as special
agent dale cooper learned
leland wasn't to blame for the death of
his daughter the real villain was bob
a demon from the black lodge who had
possessed leland decades earlier
and this dynamic is expanded on in twin
peaks fire walk with me
a movie that depicts the last days of
laura palmer during this movie
leland is eerily possessive of his
daughter has no problem
gaslighting her and when he's not
harassing laura
he's out killing sex workers instead a
kid is supposed to feel safe in her own
home and parents are supposed to take
care of their children
but poor laura can't even trust her own
dad the man who leers at her from across
the room
who sedates her mother so she won't hear
laura's screams
and who despite being possessed by a
demon is far
too realistic a villain for comfort
despite all the blood and gore
the horror genre is pretty puritanical
when it comes to sex
after all if a slasher catches you
getting it on you're probably about to
meet the sharp edge of a machete
filmmaker david robert mitchell wanted
to subvert that old trope however
so he wrote and directed it follows an
atmospheric horror film about a girl
with the world's worst
std after sleeping with a new boyfriend
for the first time
jay height learns that she got a lot
more than a sexy date
she's just received a curse in the form
of a shape-shifting creature that only
she can see
the nameless it will follow her for the
rest of her life
ambling behind her until it catches up
the only way jay can get rid of it is by
sleeping with someone else and passing
on the curse
it never speaks a word and never breaks
into anything faster than a slow walk
it just keeps on coming one step at a
time
and it never ever stops and that's
exactly what makes it so terrifying
most great horror villains have some
sort of origin story
freddy krueger was a child killer burned
by his victim's vengeful parents
michael myers was a psychopathic little
boy locked up in a mental hospital
the xenomorph had something to do with
whatever prometheus was about
it has no origin appearing in stephen
king's novel of the same name and it's
ensuing movie adaptations
this movie monster is a dark and evil
spirit who is as old and mysterious as
the universe
it's an entity that's always been here
stoking the fear of its victims before
gleefully devouring their flesh
it can appear as basically whatever you
dread most although
it most famously takes the form of
pennywise the dancing clown
pennywise has plagued the town of derry
for centuries
and has developed a particular taste for
young children as a result
pennywise's evil influence can be felt
all over dairy
and the adults are eager to turn a blind
eye to the horrors happening in their
streets
making things worse pennywise truly
enjoys what he's
doing the more afraid you are the better
he likes it
and even if you band together with all
your friends to drive him off
the dairy demon will just slink away
into the sewers and wait for round two
because no matter how hard you try evil
will always return
here's a question what if there really
is a god
and what if he hates you whether or not
you believe in a supreme being
it's unsettling to think of an
omnipotent force that's
actively trying to destroy you after all
god is supposed to be loving
martin lang however is anything but
benevolent played to unsettling
perfection by barry kewin
martin is the teenage villain in the
killing of a sacred deer
an eerie film about a man caught in the
crosshairs of an angry deity
granted stephen murphy isn't exactly a
great guy
he's an alcoholic surgeon who
negligently killed martin's dad on the
operating table
even worse he absolutely refuses to take
any blame for his mistakes or
acknowledge any wrongdoing
so martin decides to use his
inexplicable powers to deliver some
old testament justice on his foe smiting
stephen's family with a plague that
involves paralysis
starvation and eventually death the only
way stephen can save his family
is by killing one of them to placate
martin what's truly upsetting is how
matter-of-fact martin is about the whole
affair he doesn't cackle or grin
he doesn't even see himself as evil he's
just out for vengeance no matter how
sadistic it might
seem and he won't stop until stephen
makes the sacrifice
you can beg you can scream you can pray
all you want
but martin won't be moved until you
finally pull the trigger
nature is supposed to behave in certain
ways but the laws governing the universe
don't apply in alex garland's
annihilation
specifically inside the shimmer a
mysterious electromagnetic field that's
growing across the southern united
states
the shimmer first appears after a
mysterious object hurtles through space
and crashes into a lighthouse and as its
boundaries expand
it creates brand new life forms mixing
and mashing the dna of the creatures
that pass through
its otherworldly walls working like a
kind of gene splicer
the shimmer occasionally creates some
beautiful cross breeds
more often however it ends up creating
hulking monstrosities that are as
dangerous as they are terrifying
take this mutant bear for example a
hideous
sickly monster the creature might be
covered in fur but its face is
made of exposed bone with a human skull
melded to the side of its head
worse still this horrific creature can
imitate the sounds of its victims
so when it hunts a group of scientists
the bear screams out the final words of
their ill-fated friend
of course the moment you react is the
one in which the bear pounces
dealing with a powerful predator is bad
enough but running from a creature
that's been perverted by nature
that's gotta be a whole lot worse check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you